what's work racism then
well racism is that there's a certain
kind of woke person
who feels that um
it's not only about being leftistly
informed but that there's this basic
proposition that we must be primarily
focused on overturning power
differentials and especially what they
call white supremacy that that must be
the focus of intellectual artistic and
moral endeavor
and if you're not doing that then you
are evil and you should be chased out of
the public square you should lose your
job you should be shamed that's a kind
of woke person with that kind of person
they're so committed to this basic
display that they know what racism is
that's it's become the
the heartbeat of a religion very much a
religion
that has become so important that even
when they do things and stick up for
things that hurt black people they don't
pay attention and they don't care
because what they really care about is
showing that they know racism exists
because that shows that they're good
people so it ends up being unintentional
but it is awoke racism and this book has
been written to blow the whistle on it
it seems like there's an inherent
connection with virtue signaling there
if the reason that people are prepared
to take a narrative over the top of its
actual impacts the reason for that is
that they're concerned with how they're
signaling to the world at large
i would even put it as the virtue
signaling has become a religion instead
of just something that people do idly
and it's really scary to see because
people will
fiercely virtue signal and claim that
what they're doing is creating social
justice they're claiming that it's for
other people but they're much less
concerned with the other people than
they really would be if we hadn't gone
from politics to a religion what do you
think is the genesis of this obsession
that we've got with race at the moment
well it's two things
one is that um the george floyd murder
was particularly egregious
and it happened and i don't make i don't
want this to sound like people were
being deliberately cynical but it
happened at a time when america was on
lockdown everybody was stuck inside
everybody was lonely and bored and angry
and it was spring and so i think
there was an extent to which people
valued the opportunity to go outside to
make some noise to interact with other
people i think if that hadn't happened
during the pandemic it wouldn't have
been at such a fever pitch because
george floyd's death was egregious but
unfortunately we see things like that
regularly in the united states it wasn't
that different but there was that and
then there was also that we have social
media now and so even if there had been
a pandemic i'm trying to be an
experimental social scientist which is
not my job but if there had been a
pandemic 10 years ago and everybody had
been stuck inside and a man had been
killed the way george floyd was i don't
think that all of this would have
happened because there was no twitter
yet or twitter wasn't as influential but
people can communicate and kind of whip
one on whip one another up with a speed
and a fervor that just technologically
wasn't possible until really over the
past under 15 years so combine the
pandemic and social media and you end up
in this bizarre new moment where
self-involved radicalism is being put
forth as the heartbeat of progressivism
on race and we've got to undo that and
get back to whatever we were doing
before just how racist is america at the
moment
it's kind of racist you know it is um
prescribed to be openly racist to a
degree that i think
we're beginning to forget how
extraordinary it is and the ordinary
educated person examines themselves for
personal racist bias
there are societal inequities where
black people clearly are behind for
reasons that you can't blame on black
people themselves and that's what's
called awkwardly societal racism i don't
like that term but there are racial
inequities in this society that often
are based on racism in the past almost
never racism in the present but they can
be what are called legacies of what
happens what is some examples of those
well so for example if um
black kids
are less likely to embrace school
the reason for it is not that black
people are dumb but it's because in the
past when schools were desegregated
white kids and teachers were so hostile
against the black kids coming in that a
meme developed of thinking of school as
the white man's game that was racism now
that same sentiment got passed along as
just one way of being a cliquish
teenager and today you'll have a black
kid who feels like if i really like
school it's like i'm doing something for
other people not my own people it's a
legacy of racism in the past but it's
not about racism now that really throws
a lot of people some one writer has
called it racism without racists and
that there's very little room for that
in our current discussion all right so
why do you call woke racism or
anti-racism a religion
it is a religion because there's a part
of it that it's allowed to proceed
without addressing logic there's a part
of many religions that entails that you
give up
logical sequential thinking in favor of
suspension of disbelief that's part of
many religions and when it comes to this
modern anti-racism you were supposed to
suspend that disbelief when questions
come up that are inconvenient
to the general paradigm and so for
example if you are a black man in an
underserved community
you are in more danger of being killed
than say i am
now if you're going to be killed the
chances that you're killed by a stray
white cop are infinitesimal the chances
that you're going to be killed by
somebody just like you from six blocks
away if you are going to be killed are
much much much higher
under our debate we scream to the
heavens about the cop
and just pay lip service to the fact
that there's a problem within black
communities themselves and that's
because the religion says you show that
you're aware of racism and so that
automatically makes the stray white cop
interesting and it turns your head away
from the murders being committed in much
greater numbers by people within
underserved communities that's religion
the fact that if you bring that up to
people they get irritated that there's a
belief system that it's in commensurate
with it's religion because frankly
there's no answer it's not that somebody
like me is missing something it's simple
any ten-year-old could figure it out and
yet you're treated and this is why it's
also a religion you're treated as a
heretic for bringing up the question and
pushing it it's a religion because if
you don't agree you're pushed out a
window if it were just an ideology it
would be i don't like how you're talking
about that that's the way it was say 20
years ago today it's if you are against
the way i think
you have to leave you can't work here
you shouldn't teach this course you
should go to another town that's
religion because that is exactly how the
fundamentalist christian used to treat
heretics and so the terminology is
different but people who are woke
racists treat people who don't agree
with them as if they were heretics
that's exactly the sentiment and they
behave exactly the way prosecutorial
christians behaved in medieval europe
exactly it's not about physical
punishment but the sentiment is the same
including wanting to deprive people of
their livelihoods what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace